yo you had a full circle moment winning
a ring and ending your career with the
Warriors obviously being a part of the
uh we believe run was
I mean
that [ __ ] I know you guys didn't get out
of the second round but getting out of
that first round against Dirk and the
Mavericks was so crazy yeah
um and that team was just so much fun to
watch but can you take me to that
Championship run I I know you know at
that point you were a veteran on the
team
um
but what how how high was the animosity
between the Warriors and the Cavaliers
because I had Iman on and he said it was
he's like that [ __ ] was up for real he
was like the group chats were active we
were it just felt like it was because it
you know they they've gone to battle
several times you know for it you know
what I mean and then you know Cleveland
got one I think that's about 20 dollars
that had two
um
for the two or three maybe two the one
we won was the third the other one one
more so
um it was intense you know for me
personally you know it was crazy because
so I leave I sign a uh you know a
three-year deal with Sacramento thinking
that all right you know just finish I'm
gonna go finish it uh finish up at home
we got a new Arena maybe make the
playoffs and you know you know get ready
for my transition so I wasn't tripping
with us and uh so then the king's trade
DeMarcus Cousins at the at during the
All-Star break like why he's on the
podium make sure the Pelicans yeah he
gets told he gets traded so you know
we're to the point where they're trying
to go younger you know I I'm talking to
manager like I'm too old to try to
rebuild like you know help me out yeah
let me get up out of here you know I
mean and they were on the same Vibe so
got released from there but they still
had to pay me uh you know the rest of my
contract because it's guaranteed and
then we're really literally
simultaneously when that happened KD
gets hurt for Golden State when they're
in DC hyper extends his knee
so uh you know I get a call from their
team to you know Katie's down you know
we're gonna need you to come out I was
like [ __ ] easy call you know what I mean
not too far from home enough you know so
I went out there
um you know the first night you know I
played like 20 25 minutes so it was dope
because it was just like I've never
played on a team that had so many stars
but it was just selfless like going to
work every day was dope the energy in
the weight room after the game
everything was just damn I see why you
[ __ ] be winning all this [ __ ]
like it's fun to be here you know like
Eagle this basketball no it's crazy no I
go out there playing I'm playing
anywhere you know 8 20 22 24 minutes a
game
in the very first game Katie comes back
is about a week before the playoffs or
maybe a week to 10 days for the playoffs
and the game he comes back
I sprained my ankle and nearly break it
the worst sprain of my [ __ ] career
and uh I was out I kept trying to come
back and I just I wasn't ready and by
the time I felt halfway decent I'm just
like damn I want to try because this is
you know we're heading to the finals
like it was a Western Conference Finals
like we're already eight now so as a vet
I knew I wasn't you know you know a role
player is not going to really go to jump
in and you know if you're a star coming
back it's a different story so I just
kind of had to you know
stay in shape just in case they needed
me stay ready and then you know talk to
guys when I saw stuff you know I mean
even though I you know I was new there
those guys like again they you know they
respected you know my body of work and
how hard I played so I wasn't someone
who was overstepping my bounds but
there'd be times where at any time you
know that's the thing cool thing about
it were out of that conversation with
Draymond had you know long conversations
with Clay you know I mean Katie used to
get down after games you know burn a few
and just talk about the game you know
what I mean so it was just like that
kind of OG
positivity and ways to look at things
and
and that team ended up winning
Championship you know what I mean but
yeah they had man handled the Cavaliers
that year that's for sure yeah no that
that was even though those teams were
cheat codes you know I mean once Katie
got healthy and staff and clay and Trey
and Iggy and I just don't like like if
Katie would have just stayed on the
Warriors who knows how many more rings I
mean it would have been ugly I was so I
was actually very happy that he left
because I felt like the balance of power
readjusted in the league for a couple of
years it was more about Duos and not
trios anymore so it was like I like the
way it is now there's parody in the
Western Conference specifically there's
so much yeah there's just so much I just
mean like if you look at like the sons
or the eight seed right now but they're
four and a half games behind the One
season I mean yeah you can make a five
game win seven game winning streak and
and you know jump up four spots or you
can go on a three or four game lose the
streak and slide down three or four
spots like the West is
super tight so let's go